manchmal bist du herzlich willkommen wir
heute an dienstag natürlich selbst
verstärkt in die sonne
sie starten wir noch mit dem letzten tag
der woche
[Musik]
danke übrigens für die zwei millionen
abonnenten auftrag es ist wirklich
bemerkenswert wie viele leute von euch
sich dort auf mein profil verliert haben
machen allerdings direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten kick auf video was glaube ich
jeder von uns kennt ihr wisst bescheid
[Musik]
alle die den insidern nicht verstehen
denken sich jetzt warum belegt
mundharmonika
hallo
am besten wäre es gewesen wenn sie auch
noch beim unternehmen der schale sich
das dann selbst über den kopf gekippt
hatte wenn ich da bin
okay ich bin neidisch
[Musik]
warum das stinkt doch gerade eventuell
nicht verstanden haben er hat als ein
tacker verloren und hat deswegen einen
zettel angefertigt auf den mal drauf
steht ist noch immer in tucker hat den
an einen filter halt eher der ich glaube
jeder hat es verstanden
[Musik]
kann jemand mal diesen komischen my best
friend we check stoppen oder alle leute
die das machen einfach grundsätzlich
blockieren von der plattform ich weiß
nicht ob ich der einzige bin aber ich
kenne meine familie schon zu gut dass
ich allein vom höheren des schrittes
bekommt
ich glaube dass
das ist normal dass man ist
warum
bekomme ich sowas auf meine frau page
[Musik]
stop dollar kann ich da nicht rein
fußball das ist so dass das stimmt
fordert in das ist ebenso muscat yoga
und qi gong li das central station
das ist halt auch wieder so das ding
wenn man so deutsche redewendungen ins
englische übersetzt es macht einfach nie
sinn so eissing als beider hat auch auf
deutsch macht das keinen sinn ich glaube
ja wohl ich spinne
ach wie schön da draußen spielen
ich frage ihn so wer nachdenkt wenn ich
nicht treffe ich glaube jeder ich glaube
ich kann ich hoffe genug machen
[Musik]
hundertprozentig zum form gepasst hat
zum beat wie das ding darunter ein
bisschen traurig habe ich ja auch ein
bisschen geheult aus meiner nase alles
klar wie hartmann lisa marie watt was
ihrem anliegen haben und nie hat man
einen speichelfluss ein bisschen
kontrollieren
aber das ist ja dieser neuer instagram
effekt den jetzt gerade jeder teste
somit kommt irgendwas vorgeschlagen muss
dann erraten was gemeint ist und eine
andere person hier auf zick zack hat das
auch nicht so ganz verstanden
[Musik]
auf blauen
ja weiter geht bei dem tic toc dachte
ich mir im ersten moment hey da ist doch
hundertprozentig ein kleiner
durchsichtiger faden an dem schläger
aber nie der typ kann das wirklich und
das sieht man auch spätestens wurde das
sich irgendwie um die beine um haut und
sodann geht dass er kein fan der serie
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
das
ist die wahrheit nicht so sehr
ich habe gesehen wie er dass der tausch
hat
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich glaube ich bin noch nie so hoch
gekommen in meiner stimme
darunter zweimal genießt das frauchen
dann beide male gesagt bless you also
gesundheit und danach ist es in ordnung
passt ist okay und dann der hund einfach
nur so
rott alte markus s
krass geil dafür diesmal wieder
entwickler von sandra dabei haben
moment ja nicht mein führerschein in
diesem schild steht dass wir uns
verfälschenden acht nehmen sollen so
werden wir genau hinsehen merken wir wir
sehen gar keine frische das liegt daran
dass diese erst für menschen ab 30
gefährlich sind
ich sehe dem tag entgegen an dem wir
einen tick tock hughes erfolge ohne
diese beiden voll chaoten haben ich
kenne das auch von mir persönlich man
hat ein bisschen hoffnung dann gewinnt
man zutrauen dann ist man inhaltlich
etwas entspannter und schon ist man auch
ein bisschen leichtsinnig ja ich glaube
es ist für viele mädchen rhi label und
vielleicht auch für viele jungs aber wie
gut war dieser lip sync bitte egal
[Musik]
das hat er nicht gebracht
das
ich hoffe ihr habt es verstanden es
jedes mal so
[Musik]
ihr könnt ja mal in den kommentaren
raten was das geräusch wahr
[Musik]
mon
[Applaus]
[Musik]
e
kommt man auf solche ideen
und das gleiche frage ich mich auch beim
nächsten tipp topp denn die jungs haben
einfach ein komplettes video rückwärts
aufgenommen ich nicht
[Gelächter]
ihr bekommt von mir auf jeden fall den
ruin der woche haben wir dann allerdings
auch zum letzten tag doch fürs heutige
video und zwar es ist ein quiz bei dem
ihr zuhause mitmachen könnt ihr dürfen
nur mit ja oder nein antworten und
einfach nicht viel nachdenken
also schnell aus der pistole geschossen
antworten und let's go gibt es eine
größere zahl als 100 millionen gibt es
eine größere zahl als zehn milliarden
gibt es eine größere zahl als 100
milliarden gibt es eine größere zahl als
zehn billionen gibt es eine größere zahl
als 100 millionen und gibt es einen
größeren idioten als dich okay das ist
interessant habt ihr nein gesagt ja ich
auch an der stelle mich das heutige
jetzt allerdings aber ändern wenn lieben
freunde werde ich die heutige politik
gefallen hat das gerne einen daumen hoch
da schreibt mir eure tickets haben gerne
in die kommentare wenn ihr in die
nächste folge top gear kommen wollte und
ich hab doch laser luca also schaut dort
gern bei mir vorbei jetzt befinden uns
allerdings auch im auto liegen ist es
weil die eingeblendet wenn darauf könnte
ich meinen kanal abonnieren wir dennoch
keine lust ihr seid dann verpasst
nämlich keine videos mehr dass das
kostenlos also kriegt doch gern mal
drauf und hier ist ein neues video
gerade auch auf meinem 2 kanal online
gegangen also klickt dort gern mal drauf
wir haben eh alle gerade nichts zu tun
mit quarantäne
also klickt das